yes i am so let's get started
ah here we go
[Music]
my favorite champion
this is probably the section we saw in
the trailer
well this place is absolutely crawling
with the eager members
how did they how did they even get in
so to do that in addition to the usual
high-rewards
action i have to oh we see the stasis in
the action again
we saw that before but it's always cool
to see
each character can use all
so the yiga blade masters are kind of
like like mini bosses
in a sense and the foot soldiers just
regular regular grunts
great thank you so much chico yeah
urbosa's
gameplay is really jesus look at all
that lightning
has such a badass her ability to
use an attack with lightning um she
has a unique ability to charge up
lightning uh which
is represented so they i just i'm
surprised i only noticed this now but so
they're they are actually playing an
english build of the game now
which really helps uh use the lightning
in addition to her and the mission goal
is to defeat the yiga blade master so
yeah nice to see it in english for a
change
point counters and in her special
attacks um
and if if chico can get the timing right
after some of these big attacks where
there's yeah there we go
she can um charge up her electricity
super quick um which
takes a lot of skill and a lot of timing
but
it's uh you see that guy flying with fly
away
and i just wanted to add too um aside
from the gameplay that you're seeing
well first of all
oh wait no oh my gosh wait they're
koroks in the game
so clearly wait what
um but this is the first time that
people get to play all right
[Music]
um but what i did want to say is fans
can look forward to
oh i hope we get to see see zelda
playable as well this time
they've been teasing us for way too long
with that stuff
well look
and get to know them in ways that you
didn't get to in breath of the wild
this game is your opportunity to do that
that's right it's it's really there's a
lot to unpack in here
and a lot to see and it's very thrilling
for fans
of breath of the wild i love that move
take a look
just it's just like in the in the memory
of verbosa
where she snaps her fingers all right
and now we're taking
there we go zelda's gameplay there we go
best girl um as you can see she
uses importance as her main attacks
what is this in addition to being able
to
use them uh just like everyone else
wow her gameplay looks so unique create
different combinations
of rooms to take out so awesome forms of
enemies
jesus in a very unique way
so she like pulls those boxes out of the
ground so you don't have to
like in breath of the wild you need to
actually be in the vicinity of a box you
can
just spawn them pretty much everywhere
for me
there we have the huge bomb again
enemies of zelda it's pretty much a win
for me
because zelda is all the game
yeah well that did a lot of damage
holy crap look at the size of those
bombs
it's actually kind of comedical
all right going back to herbosa now
[Music]
looks like there's a lot of people here
oh my god just look at how many of them
as you can see there are prompts on the
screen that help guide you
i don't think they would all fit inside
the base
to be can turn those honest if you want
to
so uh i'm at this location and it looks
like my um
objective is to defeat the enemies with
a loud attack
so i think i need to do
oh i can't use right now but i will wait
till my
my room fills up first but
make some noise chico
this guy is really getting in your way
so as you can see uh when you use the
shika room
there is a little bit of a wait time for
it to charge back up before you can use
it again
um which is very similar to how it
worked boom
oh man that was that was a gorgeous
take out right there
so we got to see a cutscene loud attacks
was to call forth a certain familiar uh
monster oh it's some malduga
oh man oh my yeah i would run too
i think he's beautiful
yeah he's too scary and he's coming
after me i don't think i want to do this
bye bye now let's go ahead and like
let's escape to the main menu while we
can
so we're going to go back to the world
now they just
they just bolted because of the uh
the giant sand monster coming after them
leveling up
characters strengthening weapons and
unlocking you like no there it is
very familiar oh oh this is cool
do you want to tell us a little bit
about this
so the map actually looks pretty much
similar i heard some people say that
they
altered the map they changed they made
it smaller
but
i mean this map is pretty much ingrained
in my memory by this point but
i don't know maybe they did change some
small things but when i first saw this i
was literally screaming i don't know but
it was so bad i never actually realized
how big central hyrule
is because
when you're playing the stages like the
borders are pretty big
so using those materials you can unlock
different locations
on the map like the stables uh other
training grounds
and uh and even like you know different
dishes
uh you can cook type thing so
one of the things i wanted to show is
actually
here uh blacksmith oh
it is a high warriors game so you will
be collecting a lot of different weapons
while you are in the stage uh not like
rest of the world oh this is interesting
stuff
the weapons do not break during the
stage but you can use these
weapons you collected to strengthen your
primary use weapon so you know
right now i'm using uh this uh sword but
there's other different type of weapons
i can get
and different you know way to use it so
he doesn't have the master sword right
now
looks like and then fuse them with all
the materials i got so
far with the level one
soup ladle that you will not neglect
[Laughter]
up to five different weapons and you can
strengthen
and you of course have to use a rupee so
make sure you collect the rupees when
you
are in the stage two i hope they put
blacksmiths in
breath well too as well that would be so
dope
so you can fuse weapons and you can also
use materials to
to strengthen them that's helpful
and you need the materials five fish
so i have the trout
now i love that dish so i can earn the
recipe for chili fish skewer
all right right and the recipe
can be used to give your characters a
little bit of a
buff before you go into battle um and
there are a bunch of different types
that have different effects so yeah this
is actually pretty cool you can
it's like basically like side quests
almost
not really because you're not really
going to lure lynn but
yeah so by defeating monsters and
getting those materials so you can also
turn them into these other
uh quests which you can use to unlock uh
bonus combos or extra health or
other such things um they're showing a
lot of stuff
is that they have little stories um that
go along with them
um little glimpses into the characters
lives between battles during this war
um the one that we just did for example
is about a young child in hoteno village
who wants to build
a monster dummy so that they can
practice uh
using a two-handed sword and so link
actually brings the materials to make
the dummy creates this dummy helps them
build it
and then they train together and that's
how link is able to come up with an
extra move for his two-handed sword
um and i love it because link's from
huntano village
so it's very cute glimpse ooh did she
just
drop some secret lure on us so he is
from ateno village
because that was never really confirmed
before
type so i know she could just be making
it up but
i don't know
pretty cool to hear someone from
nintendo actually say it
so i changed my weapon and i guess i can
take that tire
yeah yeah you can unlock different
pieces
of armor as you progress through the
game and you can
equip or i guess unequipped
just kidding also this is the chili fish
skewer we just got from the recipe
location so i can use that
right and every character will react
differently to
the uh dishes that you cook for them
um and some characters even have
favorite dishes
we have the warping different when you
give them their favorite dish
so it's a lot of fun to try out a bunch
of different recipes they took
so much uh your characters like
they really took the game like breath of
the wild and translated it perfectly
uh live stream you might have seen the
uh cut scene where it's showing the
tower
actually raising from the ground and uh
tower is actually going to be a base oh
we can see all the little character
sprites
dude actually that character's pride of
link really does look like the one from
the
uh 10 000 years ago battle
we have r2d2
oh [ __ ] well
i mean
wait why is he fighting soldiers
like who are they who are these people
yeah so
wait let's see real quick what what is
which location
this is the ranch right
yeah this is definitely the ranch
i have no idea why there's human enemies
now but how it was used in breath of the
wild
um oh okay so it's training it's uh i'm
an idiot it says on the side defeat
training opponents but the
fun fun thing about it is that holy [ __ ]
he like stops it in his face he's like
um in exchange he takes a little hulk
mode
activated like that
oh my god these poor soldiers they're
getting whacked around like crazy
[Music]
look at how much buildings and
structures there's actually around this
place
like if you look in the distance like
guessing that's the central hyrule tower
probably
oh no not quite okay so but one of those
animations is highly aggressive so this
is
this is a wrench great to see it finally
as well
we'll get an opportunity to show you
that because i love it
oh my god i love this
is just shirtless walking around this
ranch with a hammer
whacking everyone stuffing food in his
mouth
and going hulk mode
oh my god 10 out of 10 guys to
breath of the wild and people who played
it like i did um
which is to say having a uh stock
highland captain or something highland
captain
my inventory so i could chow down when
i'm
being blown back by a strong attack that
did lots of damage
you can aggressively eat your apples and
send those soldiers aggressively eat
your apples
i was so confused when i saw those
soldiers i really thought like wait
is link going rogue is he uh or is like
the hylian army going rogue
but no it's just a training session
i'd also like to point out that this
location
is very familiar um it appeared
i could see the ranch tower as well
breath of the wild but now
before the calamity it's in its heyday
and uh it's very cool to see what it
looked like when it
before it got destroyed yes it does
yeah in chico maybe you can show us um
some light lightning rod
action oh yeah we did get to see the ice
rod before
yeah yeah that one
four i kind of missed what she said
about the
the wrench itself like did she call it
long long wrench or i'd have to
re-watch it after this because i was
focusing on the gameplay but
because they don't really call it long
long range in the game
it's just called the ranch ruins and
create an opening
so you can do a counter attack
which can be very powerful
this is a hell of a training session
i love the two-handed sword so much
i think it's my favorite it's so
satisfying you know to just slam through
all of these enemies you know these
thousands and thousands of enemies
and also to like take a little break to
have a snack here and then
it's a lot of fun absolutely this is my
favorite one
i'm hoping we can i know your favorite
[Music]
i'm still kind of wondering how they
will explain them all using the runes
because
at first i thought it was the tiny
guardian doing it but
i'm not so sure because he's not always
around he is around this time but
okay we got some lag we have to fight
the rook
oh man i don't want to fight the rook he
moves surprisingly quickly for someone
of his thighs though i have to say
all right it is pretty cool though
seeing these two duke it out but
you can do it chico i believe in you
give me your
own size
oh my goodness oh my gosh oh jesus
poor daruk man for training
i take our training very seriously
the roof just went flying
all right let's cut away from this for a
second training has ended
you've killed all your friends
okay so they have more for us i love
daruk he's so great
i like this woman already fun character
the rook is the man it's cool to see all
the various characters second favorite
champion by the way some people have
been asking me about my favorite
champions it's urbosa then
uh daruc ravali mifa i'm sorry
nifa is just not the most interesting
character to me i like their
relationship between her and link and
stuff like that
but just in terms of personality or i
don't know i guess
it's an amazing thing i like all of them
though it's not like uh
flat out dislike one of them but if i
had to choose
that would be the order of how they
interact and how they
uh perform in battle um it's stuff that
that
i think personally is a fan of breath of
the wild i wished for
so hard was the the chance to be able to
see these guys
in their prime so it's it's a lot of fun
yeah and and not to not to bring the
soup ladle up too much
but i do want to say i love that they
included
that they included the soup ladle you
know that they're they're bringing it
back
and we see those same touches from
breath of the wild in this game
and chico mentioned that the weapons
aren't breakable so
you really could oh yeah they did say
that the weapons are not breakable
your voices have been heard still
remains to be seen if that's going to be
the case in breath while too as well but
i don't know for this game it works
better it would be
oh we got em empire again
we've seen quite a lot of gameplay of
impasso but still
i love that hang glider move she does
like a squirrel this is a new depiction
of impa
um that we're seeing here but chico is
about to show us
just what info is capable of in the
gameplay
don't you mean simpa
[Music]
all right sorry so much fun to play
she's so quick and she has these
different uh
jutsu attacks that was a giant frog
okay i got a high knocks in the
[Music]
use of the background there we go whoa
they're a lot faster in this game
wait is it he knocks or hinoks i love it
i've been calling them high knocks for
the longest time but
nobody knows how to pronounce stuff in
zelda anyway
it's really fun takes a lot of strategy
and timing
nice and you can see her
uh her chica room usage
does differ from the other characters
we've looked at today too
something i really like about this game
is the hits like when you actually hit
something
or someone it just feels so satisfying
like the sound it makes nintendo's
always been good at that stuff you know
strong enemies um and it's even more
important that you do that when fighting
these things oh my god
[Music]
and it really is vital they're
surprisingly agile those
those hidden oxes and it can really make
it easy to
uh or easier i should say to take these
guys out
to take out the four hands that was
he got frozen mid-roll
that's fair
oh she called it a squirrel too
great minds think alike
i just now noticed that we actually hear
her voice
i mean it's just battle cries but
all right thanks everyone for tuning in
oh that was it calamity which releases
friday november 20th uh we hope you
enjoyed it
we sure did i sure did
thank you and bye bye
bye
so yeah that was pretty cool they showed
a lot of stuff just
outside of the fighting as well like the
the overworld map and
the the the cooking and crafting and
stuff like that
very cool
i think they shouldn't give away too
much after this
like i don't want to be spoiled too much
i want to be surprised as much as
possible i
also didn't expect robbie and pura to
see playable i'm
still on the fence if they even will be
playable i mean
i've said this on my community posts and
on twitter as well like
i really really want to play as everyone
but i also don't want him to to break
the character
you know like not everyone is a fighter
and you can just you could have to just
turn everyone into a fighter maybe
robbie would be an option
i mean they already did it with zelda
because as far as we know she never
fought
in the memories or anything like that
she was actually pretty
pretty fragile in a lot of ways but here
we see their her
totally going ham on on enemies with the
sheikah slate so
i don't know either way i don't care
whether whether or not they are playable
or not i'm gonna be hyped for this game
either way
so it was great seeing zelda playable
finally like they they had so many
opportunities where i thought they were
gonna switch to zelda
and they just didn't at the tokyo game
show and now they finally did
and she looks awesome i mean very
different than the other fighters
actually uh
but yeah that's uh that's about it for
now see ya